- [Narrator] COVID-19 has
killed more than 300,000 people
in the United States in 2020.
But that's just the known death toll.
Scientists and families who
have lost their relatives
across the country, say the real figure
is likely much higher.
- That the total number of
COVID deaths that we have
in the US is really an undercount
of the full burden of the pandemic.
- [Narrator] When the CDC
looked at how many more people
had died nationwide this year
compared to previous years,
it found that COVID-19
only accounted for around
two thirds of those deaths.
Meaning up to 100,000 additional deaths
hadn't been officially
attributed to the pandemic.
The number of additional deaths
compared to previous years
is known as excess deaths
and many experts see
it as a starting point
to determine the real death
toll from the pandemic.
- And so when we look at
2020 and the COVID deaths
there's clearly an excess mortality.
And then the question is,
what is that excess mortality made up of?
- [Narrator] That's the
puzzle that statisticians,
healthcare workers and
policy makers are all racing
to solve and it may take years.
- You know, these things
are not as black and white
as you might expect.
- [Narrator] But understanding
exactly how people die
can help governments fight
the virus more effectively
and determine things such as
where to send vaccines first
and whether lockdowns are effective.
So how will we know how many people
really died from COVID in America?
- I have today declared
that the Corona virus
presents a public health
emergency in the United States.
- [Narrator] When the pandemic
first hit the US in February
epidemiologists like Dan Weinberger
from Yale Public School
of Health, began comparing
how many excess deaths they were seeing
against the official COVID death figures.
- Especially early on, there
was a pretty considerable gap
between the number of
reported COVID deaths
and the total number of
deaths that occurred.
- [Narrator] Professor
Weinberger believes that this gap
which you can see here is
caused by two main factors.
The first is a term
called collateral deaths
where people have been
killed not by the COVID virus
but have died due to the
wider impacts of the pandemic.
- In Michigan, six hospitals
have reached capacity this week.
- As hospitals are getting
more and more overwhelmed by the pandemic.
- Simply the ability to care
for people as well as we should
simply goes away.
- [Narrator] In some cases,
researchers say people have died
because healthcare
facilities were overwhelmed.
Or people simply wanted
to avoid hospitals.
- We know that especially
early on in the pandemic
a lot of people were
avoiding emergency care
for things like heart attacks and strokes.
And that can certainly contribute
to the number of people who are dying.
- [Narrator] The second
category is COVID deaths
that have been certified
as something else.
And professor Weinberger
believes it's this category
that makes up the vast
bulk of those non COVID
excess deaths.
- Determining the cause of
death for a death certificate
is a bit of an art.
There are often multiple
contributing factors.
So you can imagine that someone
gets an infection with COVID
and then they develop pneumonia,
perhaps have heart attack and die.
And then there's a question
of what gets recorded
as the underlying cause of
death on the death certificate?
- [Narrator] One person
who makes those decisions
is Dr. James Gill, Connecticut's
Chief Medical Examiner.
He has made it his mission
to find COVID deaths
that had been misclassified in his state.
- We don't want to be
just arbitrary and say,
well if they've ever been COVID positive,
we're gonna make it a COVID death, no!
You really have to look
at the circumstances
and the clinical history
and make sure that COVID-19
is still playing or played
some kind of pathologic role
in the death.
- [Narrator] Dr. Gill
started testing bodies
at funeral homes after seeing
a slew of death certificates
at the beginning of the
pandemic with pneumonia
or respiratory failure
listed as the cause.
- If it said respiratory
failure, that would give us
a tip off that maybe
this was a COVID death
that had been missed.
- [Narrator] His team
performed some 175 postmortem
COVID-19 swabs at funeral
homes in his state.
- 110 tested positive for COVID.
We were able to identify dozens of deaths
that would not have been
identified as COVID death,
but for our investigation.
- [Narrator] Dr. Gill
believes many COVID deaths
may have been missed due to a
shortage of available testing
for both the dead and the living.
Testing kits have become easier to find
after shortages in May.
- We had trouble getting
enough nasopharyngeal swabs.
To test I was calling up
local hospitals saying,
can you give me 20, can you give me 25?
They just weren't available.
Unfortunately again, people
think of the medical examiners
you're just dealing with dead people.
You don't need to be a priority.
We need to deal with the living.
And I absolutely understand
that and agree with that
to a certain point, but as I, you know
but our work does affect
the living as well.
- [Narrator] So how does
understanding how people have died
help us exactly?
- The disruptions caused by the pandemic
are obviously unprecedented
in recent history.
Having a better
understanding of the severity
of the pandemic can allow us
to make more informed choices
and can allow the public to decide whether
those decisions are justified or not.
- [Narrator] The excess deaths
data can also give insights
into how vaccines should be rolled out.
- You know, the excess
deaths particularly hit
certain vulnerable
populations especially hard,
certain lower income populations
and communities of color.
It can help in sort of
planning for the next phase
of the pandemic thinking about
who should be vaccinated
first and where we might wanna
focus prevention efforts.
(people clapping)
- [Narrator] Is there limited resources
to fight the pandemic?
This data is crucial to help
identify high priority areas
and inform policy decisions.
- In addition, people just
wanna know, a family member
you wanna know if your brother
dies, your father dies,
why did they die?
You know, is this a COVID death?
And so, you know, I hate
to use the term closure
but that is something
that I think helps people
with their bereavement and
so they can understand.
- [Narrator] But for those seeking closure
the answers may still take time.
While professor Weinberger
says data from this pandemic
is still being analyzed
at an unprecedented rate,
it's still typically takes years
to account for those
unknown excess deaths.
- Yeah, I think it is gonna take sometime
with the current pandemic,
just because we're
gonna have to be patient
and wait for the data to be released.
And that could take another
one to two years from now.